i think we have to reflect on two or
three things of a positive nature one is
that the british armed forces carried
out their duty
extremely well and professionally and
everyone can have a sense of pride as
far as that is concerned albeit that we
had to fight quite hard with the
government for the resources that we
needed to do the job and i think
secondly we need to reflect on
notwithstanding what's happened in the
last few days but that over the previous
five 10 15 years
we have helped transform
then
afghan society
make it more progressive
give women a proper place in that
society and allow girls to be educated
none of which was going on under the
taliban now i know that that is being
swept away but the issue that we have to
to watch and wait to see what happens is
what the taliban of 2021 looks like as
opposed to the taliban of 2001 but to
the soldier i don't know his name you
haven't told me who lost his legs all i
can say is that his service is
extraordinarily valued
and that he did achieve a lot but sadly
in current circumstances um strategic
errors have been made and um it looks as
if situation in afghanistan has
completely turned itself around jack
cummings former royal engineer 101
engineer regiment is who i'm talking
about um
we see the taliban with their feet up on
the presidential desk we see the brits
and those that worked with us for us
rushing to the airport to get out of the
country as quickly as they can what sort
of message does that send to others
around the world that we would try to um
get into our confidence if we were to
find ourselves in another conflict
well in the short term it sends a
terrible message
so that it sends a terrible message
about the capability of the united
kingdom but i think probably
transcending that
it says it sends a terrible message
about the degree of influence that the
united states can have i i think we
would all accept without
undue finger pointing that president
biden's
decision to withdraw all u.s and
therefore effectively all international
troops by the 20th anniversary of 9 11
just in a few days time was most
unfortunate and precipitate and it
and it is the factor which has caused
these circumstances to to unfold but i
think there's a wider point
we must
have a formal inquiry we must analyze
what happened over the last 20 years the
strategic decision making the
operational level campaign planning and
what went on on the ground and identify
the lessons and learn the lessons so
that if we are going to get involved in
another conflict another
counterinsurgency operation in the
future somewhere else in the world we
can do it better drawing on these
unfortunate experiences of afghanistan
we
you lost so many men we lost so many men
and women 459 i think during the course
of the afghan conflict um how much does
it stick in your craw to see um the
taliban flag now flying over the british
embassy
well it's it's nothing short of a
tragedy
um and
i feel it very strongly as you said in
your introduction
i was the head of the british army for
three years
when we first went back into south asia
afghanistan in 2006
and i felt responsible for the soldiers
under my command then i still feel
responsible for those soldiers who
fought in that campaign now which is why
instead of giving up and going play golf
and just um getting on with being
retired i'm very much engaged in in
these issues and doing what we can to
support our bereaved families those who
have been injured
but also as i've just said to make the
government
look at itself look in the mirror
have an inquiry decide what went right
what went wrong and learn lessons from
what went wrong so that we continue to
improve and get it right next time but
it takes nothing away and i've already
said that in this conversation the
british soldier sailor airmen and marine
on the ground did everything that was
required of them both in afghanistan and
also in iraq over the last 20 years i
have huge admiration for their
professionalism and the country should
also salute that professionalism and
dedication even if eventually
strategically not through our own fault
a tragedy has unfolded in afghanistan
can we accept that potentially the
taliban has also changed during those
two decades and they are now an
organization that we can do business
with
well i don't know okay
i think time is going to have to tell
what the taliban of 2021 looks like
compared to the taliban of 2001. if it's
the latter then i fear for much of a
civil society in afghanistan for women
in that society and for the education of
girls in particular but um we'll have to
wait and see what the taliban of 2021
looks like
however
they
can't live in isolation they will need
allies yes of course pakistan being
another islamic state will undoubtedly
um be in collaboration and cooperation
with them um i don't think they're going
to get too much truck from
iran on the other side being a sheer
muslim state
but um the taliban will have to show
themselves to be responsible if they
want to be taken seriously and if other
governments are going to recognize them
certainly as far as the british
government is concerned we want to be
very cautious before we even think about
recognizing that government to see what
it looks like to see what a civil
society is going to be looking like
and whether or not he's protecting its
people or oppressing them the chairman
of the um defense select committee
tobias elwood as you know said that you
know china is already showing the
taliban some ankles so we will have to
keep an eye on what happens as far as
that is concerned he also warned uh
about a civil war in afghanistan are you
concerned about that
well okay one has to be concerned about
that um
it's uh it's always been a fragmented
society um
i mean tobias elwood in the past is
criticized and i understand his
criticism of the attempt by the western
allies to impose a centralized a
political structure on afghanistan um
i'm not sure that we had many
alternatives i mean if we had
encouraged them to develop a fragmented
um local maybe even warlord based
society i think that would have been a
recipe for difficulty as well but um we
are where we are looking forward i think
tobias is concerned as indeed i'm
concerned that we may well find that
there is a return to civil war um the
northern alliance that was significant
in
2001
to sweep out the taliban originally i
think they've probably now withdrawn to
the uh the stars to the north they will
regroup rearm we may well see
them coming in from the north again the
south which has always been the pashtun
therefore taliban heartland will
probably remain pretty solidly behind
the taliban
so i'm afraid uh looking at afghanistan
over the next five ten years there is a
recipe for continuing conflict it's a
tragedy
we've given it a really good shot over
the last 20 years
to change afghanistan but the will of
the afghan government has been eroded
the morale of the afghan national forces
has been undermined and the
rapid advance of the taliban over the
last few days is the inevitable
consequence it is a tragedy
thank you my lord